[Music]
on this Saturday night Canada Day
Celebrations and suspensions
wild weather threatens to upstage the
Big Show in Ottawa but it doesn't dampen
the spirit I'm actually very excited
because it's like our country and we
hear from the First Nations artists at
center stage on how his music honors his
family history
highlighting hidden histories 100 years
since the Exclusion Act in the letter it
talks about the fact that you know
you know I saw you a unique look at the
legacy of the immigration ban in the
country's First Chinese Canadian Museum
now open in Vancouver BC port operations
halted this is something that affects
every community in Canada and every
family in Canada as thousands of workers
are on strike the wide-ranging job
action and how it could impact global
Shipping South Koreans get younger
overnight the new law changing the
system for counting a person's age
global national
foreign
good evening and thanks for joining us
we will get to Canada Day celebrations
in a moment but we begin with breaking
news tonight in central Alberta where a
tornado appears to have touched down
near the town of Didsbury
I think there might be another one
Witnesses caught video of the Twister
touching down about an hour north of
Calgary today RCMP say they received
reports of a large tornado in the area
this afternoon ranging from one to two
kilometers wide police say homes were
damaged and there are reports of
injuries they will provide more
information when it becomes available
there was also severe weather in the
nation's capital which threw a wrench
into Canada Day plans thousands of
people had gathered at Parliament Hill
for festivities and performances when
new warnings of thunderstorms and
possibly tornadoes put the events on
pause our chief political correspondent
David Aiken was at the daytime ceremony
earlier today he joins us now from
Ottawa with more on the situation David
now late this afternoon Environment
Canada issued a thunderstorm warning and
a tornado watch for the national capital
region and so as a result government
officials have suspended Canada Day
festivities that said the weather did
cooperate enough today that a daytime
ceremony was able to be completed and at
that ceremony new Canadians were the
stars of the show
so my name is Ralph senzie hi my name is
Jessica Sandy a brother and sister from
Haiti sharing a very special day not
Canada day though that of course is
special too but instead this their first
day as Canadian citizens so this is it
the moment you've been
okay we're among 17 people who became
new Canadians at this National Canada
Day ceremony I swear
Minister joined in
and then Ralph Jessica are welcome from
the countries PM Canada is now
officially your home
welcome my friends
that was very emotional knowing the
story like going back to history that
was very very emotional I know
they even got a shout out from Canadian
astronaut Jeremy Hansen picked to be the
first Canadian to visit the moon and I
have to say congratulations for everyone
here is experiencing Canada day as new
citizens uh welcome to Canada you know
really like
I don't I don't think I have enough
words I enjoyed every single second of
it everything was just blew my mind it
definitely was a celebration
um and we felt that it was it definitely
welcomed Us in the ceremony closed with
the national anthem
[Music]
singing their anthem for the first time
as Citizens
homes yes
days ago
special Milestone the population of the
country is now 40 million that's right
40 million Canadians and these days that
population growth is driven by record
high immigration levels as the country
welcomes people like Jessica and Ralph
me too David Aiken from the Canada Day
celebrations in Ottawa thanks David
as always there are plenty of ways to
celebrate Canada day but as night falls
not everyone will get to see the
fireworks there are bans on private
pyrotechnics in many provinces because
of the Wildfire risks and some cities
have chosen other ways to celebrate
there will be fireworks across Atlanta
Canada with Charlottetown marking the
150th anniversary of Pei joining
Confederation as Canada's seventh
Province the fireworks display in
Montreal has been canceled over air
quality concerns from smoke and
wildfires
Ottawa is expected to have fireworks
after tonight's National concert but
only if the weather cooperates the city
of Toronto has organized several
fireworks displays in Winnipeg you can
see a drone display downtown or
fireworks at the racetrack on the
western edge of the city Regina and
Saskatoon are both planning fireworks
the skies above Edmonton and Calgary
will also light up after Calgary
reversed a decision earlier this year to
tone down its fireworks display and
Vancouver decided to cancel its
fireworks focusing instead on daytime
activities in a spirit of indigenous
reconciliation several suburbs however
will still have fireworks
foreign
an indigenous musician who's been chosen
to play at the Canada Day celebrations
in Ottawa why he accepted the honor and
how his grandfather helped shape his
music
now though we turn to France a funeral
service was held today for 17-year-old
who is known as nael his killing by
police Unleashed days of unrest across
the country
[Applause]
riding and looting raged in cities for a
fourth night despite a deployment of 45
thousand police officers more than 1300
people were arrested overnight French
president Emmanuel macron has now
postponed a planned State visit to
Germany now a 17 year old of Algerian
and Moroccan descent was fatally shot
during a traffic stop on Tuesday his
death has reignited long-standing
complaints by poor and racially mixed
urban communities
a strike is now underway for thousands
of Port workers in British Columbia
federally mediated talks failed to reach
an agreement between the two sides the
ports along with the West Coast are
critical for Canadian trade and global
Shipping Global's Travis Prasad is
following the story for us tonight
Travis
need to you can see the picketers behind
me making the rounds outside of the
maritime employer's office near the
Vancouver Port they're just some of the
more than 7 400 Port workers who've
walked off the job along BC's Coast
bringing Port operations to a halt
a sure sign of a strike negotiations
between the international Longshore and
Warehouse Union of Canada and the BC
Maritime employers Association went well
into the night on Friday but no progress
was made there couldn't be a worse way
to celebrate Canada today than to deal
with something like that it's job action
on the west coast that could devastate
the entire country's supply chain still
in recovery from the pandemic we do
about 800 million dollars worth of trade
through those ports every day and about
a quarter of the trade between Canada
and the rest of the world passes through
those ports so this is something that
affects every community in Canada and
every family in Canada the union has
been without a contract since March as
it pushes for a new deal that addresses
three key concerns stop the erosion of
work through outside contracts protect
jobs from Port Automation and make sure
earnings keep up with the cost of living
the employers Association says their
bargaining committee has made repeated
efforts to be flexible and find
compromise on key priorities but
regrettably the parties have yet to be
successful in reaching a settlement
the union has not responded to requests
for comment labor Minister Sheamus o
Reagan confirms both parties remain at
the bargaining table and federal
mediators are involved hopeful for a
timely resolution for every day that a
strike goes ahead it probably takes
about a week for the supply chain to get
back to normal so if we look at it for a
long strike for you know seven days we
could be looking at 28 to two months to
get it back to normal and the supply
chain impacts could last even longer
than that the freight management
association says with U.S ports open
shipments could be diverted South of the
Border with no guarantee of that
business ever coming back to Canada
Travis Prasad in Vancouver tonight
thanks Travis
remembering a controversial law 100
years later coming up how the Exclusion
Act negatively impacted thousands of
Chinese Canadians plus why millions of
people in South Korea became younger
overnight
[Music]
this country's first Museum dedicated to
Chinese Canadian history has opened its
doors in Vancouver's Chinatown it marks
the 100th anniversary of a controversial
1923 law that halted Chinese immigration
to Canada for decades the Museum's board
chair says the date was chosen as a
reminder of a part of Canadian history
that's often overlooked its first
exhibition is called the paper trail to
the 1923 Chinese Exclusion Act it
showcases documents issued to Chinese
Canadians to highlight their segregated
status
a century on many Chinese Canadians
still feel conflicted over July 1st
celebrations Mike drolet looks at how
the shameful act shaped this country and
several of the citizens who helped build
it
July 1st with all the fireworks and
celebrations to Mark Confederation has
been known as Canada day since 1982.
many Chinese Canadians have historically
used a different name humiliation day
1920s Canada wasn't kind to the Chinese
immigrants who from the railroads to the
Gold Rush helped to build the country as
thanks and amidst openly racist articles
and cartoons the government enacted the
Chinese Exclusion Act on July 1st 1923
banning all immigration for the next 24
years only less than 50 people of
Chinese origin actually were allowed in
Fred Wong's father paid a 500 head tax
to enter Canada for work in 1922
returning to China briefly in 1933 to
get married and father child and then
didn't see either for another 13 years
because of the Exclusion Act the letters
from his father he says are
heartbreaking also in the in the letter
it talks about the fact that you know
you know it's been 10 years since I saw
you after the Exclusion Act was
abolished in 1947 Paving the way to
citizenship and the right to vote his
family was reunited he says they lived
with the fear it could happen again it's
something that was ingrained in me as a
as a child you know basically stay out
of trouble
don't don't raise attention to yourself
just you know
continue on you know and move forward
you're talking about one newly elected
Toronto mayor Olivia Chao the first
Asian to hold the position remembers
when an older Chinese woman brought her
husband's head tax certificate to her in
1983. she put out a call for more and
had over 350 Chinese Canadians come
forward and I pledge to them in 1983
I'll do what I can
to seek Justice and by gosh it took a
long time
23 years to be precise before then Prime
Minister Stephen Harper apologized in
Chinese in the House of Commons that she
said mattered it was like an open wound
that we felt that if you don't deal with
it people will not learn from history
and learning history means that
hopefully it won't repeat itself July
1st will be a day of internal conflict
for many Chinese Canadians who would
much rather celebrate the good than
revisit difficult memories but they
understand why on the 100th anniversary
it needs to be remembered can Canada is
a society that we Embrace diversity we
Embrace tolerance and we are perhaps one
of the best
Multicultural Societies in the world and
we need to remember that we do have this
painful past so hopefully we will not
not let that happen again microlight
Global News Toronto
[Music]
suddenly years younger ahead the South
Korean law changing the age of its
citizens
[Music]
more than 50 million people in South
Korea got a little bit younger this week
the country is changing the way people
traditionally count their age and for
almost everyone that means overnight
they got to age backwards Mike Armstrong
explains
there seem to be more jokes than
complaints about what is for South
Koreans a fairly big change a turning
back of the clock for everyone
this woman says she and her friends have
been feeling great about getting younger
starting today all South Koreans become
younger people aren't quite Aging in
reverse the country is adopting what it
calls the system of international age
dropping South Korea's traditional way
of counting in fact two ways of counting
it's a little complicated
now here's how the system worked with
the help of a major South Korean export
squid game
main actor is 50 years old but but 52 in
traditional Korean age and 51 in
counting age
the actor was born December 15 1972.
well the traditional South Korean system
factors in the pregnancy so when
someone's born they're already
considered a year old then when the
calendar year changes they become
another year old
which means just a month after being
born the actor was in Korean age already
considered two years old the counting
age system doesn't include the time in
the womb but you age a year each
calendar year thank you so much those
systems are being dropped almost
entirely
the government says the new system
should cut down on confusion and legal
disputes it came into effect Wednesday
although the other counting system does
still apply to the age for school
conscription and drinking for now
this man says he was worried he'd be
banned from buying alcohol because the
legal drinking age is 19 and overnight
he went from 20 to 18. he's been
grandfathered in polls show most South
Koreans are behind the move it does
after all delay those big round
Benchmark birthdays although some will
have to turn 50 twice that really
doesn't seem fair Mike Armstrong Global
News
[Music]
indigenous inspiration next singer Ace
and Abby reflects on his journey and
Heritage ahead of his Canada Day
performance
[Music]
celebrate
[Applause]
[Music]
the evocative voice of Ethan Alby from
Sandy Lake first nation in Northwestern
Ontario tonight if the weather holds out
Ace and Abby will take the stage for the
Canada Day celebrations in Ottawa I
spoke with him a little earlier today
Ace and Abby thanks for joining us first
of all can you tell us about your
journey as a musician and how you got to
where you are today
you know I started playing music when I
was 12 years old and it was just kind of
a
lack of things to do I grew up in a
house without electricity running water
you know in Canada and uh I I started
playing guitar you know there was a
guitar around I started writing songs
and uh
did that yeah until I moved to Toronto I
came here to play music but then ended
up
going to college and it was kind of
you know my career started taking off I
guess during the pandemic
I uh I spent the first year of the uh
the pandemic interviewing my grandfather
and then you know after a year
I had kind of listened to those those
recordings and then I wrote a song I
wrote two songs and decided I'd make an
album and I thought it would take maybe
you know four or five years when I
wasn't too tired from work to kind of
work on this project
and then I met Amanda rayom and shoshona
Kish from Ishq Day Records one of the uh
the first indigenous and women-owned
labels in the country and and
they asked me what I was working on and
I told them
and yeah they signed me they signed me I
didn't even have a record done you know
that's very rare in the music industry
to sign somebody with no track record no
one's really heard of them they don't
even have a record ready for them to
listen to
so they took a chance on me and you know
Flash Forward a year and a half
we went to the junos we got Polaris
prize nominated we got all these
you know accolades as far as the music
industry but the biggest thing for me is
you know we got to put out this record
and we got to put up the record we
wanted to
and how we wanted to put it out and uh
you know it's it's a very it's a it's a
record of a you know very heavy
conversation heavy topic it talks about
residential school and my grandfather's
experience so
um you know I had residential school
survivors reach out to me and say you
know they found this
This Record healing and they're finally
like happy to hear our stories told by
our people and our our words so
It's been a
an absolutely kind of Whirlwind year
you know from from playing music in my
my living room during lockdown to
playing you know the biggest stages in
the country
I can imagine and you mentioned your
grandfather can you tell us more about
your grandfather's influence on your
music and in shaping your artistic path
yeah so I uh
my grandfather like that the whole the
album we put out in November is
written in calling response and it's uh
they're all his stories you know
um and so it isn't just music it's part
journalism I used to work as a
journalist too actually so like you know
it's it's kind of these two worlds kind
of colliding and
so yeah it's storytelling it's music and
it's my grandfather's story and it's
it's not uh you know sadly it's not an
uncommon story like that story is is the
story of a lot of indigenous families
across the country
it is indeed and being selected to
perform on the Canada Day stage is an
honor how does it feel to have this
opportunity especially representing the
indigenous community at a time when many
more Canadians are rethinking how they
Mark the country's birthday
yeah first off yeah like I'm honored to
be invited to be asked to play but it's
yeah you know it doesn't come without
mixed feelings I have a lot of peers who
turn down Canada Day shows because you
know a lot of things have been coming to
light things that indigenous people have
already been talking about for years
decades and um
but I don't know for me I think
you know strong dialogue still needs to
happen and it has been happening
obviously strong action needs to happen
more but
you know it's important for indigenous
people to be in these spaces you know
we're we're here too and we need to be
able to kind of hold space and and you
know tell our stories through our music
and and you know it's a day of
Celebration but it's also a day of
reflection and so I'm happy to be a part
of that reflection
that was acen Abbey joining us from
Ottawa earlier today and that is global
national for this Saturday I'm nitu
garcha tonight here Canada is the Roger
Center in Toronto where the Blue Jays
are in action with special red and white
uniforms in front of a sellout crowd for
Canada Day to Mark the occasion the team
held a variety of pre-game celebrations
including a Canadian citizenship
ceremony where some of our newest
citizens got to throw a ceremonial pitch
thanks so much for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]
thank you